[Music]
[Applause]
as we bring in mariana rivera the hall
of famer won five world series titles
with the yankees and uh he's helping
start a new pro league pro baseball in
dubai
the first created to serve a billion
people across india
uh pakistan the middle east united
international baseball league and uh
probably going to tap into that cricket
uh fandom the ownership group includes
uh barry larkin with mariano rivera who
joins us how would you do facing uh
somebody in cricket
damn thank you man uh that would be
great because i mean uh i have a lot of
space to uh
to uh face one of those great hitters of
cricket so i mean
the one thing then that they are grown
out they hit the ball from every angle
so that's great though so i have to i
have to be
sharp on my [ __ ] and it's more
um if finish this sentence if you would
state a starting pitcher
dot dot dot
if i would have been
saying that again if you would have
stayed
what did you start 10 games and yeah so
if you had stayed a starting pitcher
if i were to stay and start a picture
then
i would have been home
were you almost gonna not make it like
at some point were they gonna say you
know you're not gonna cut it as a
starter
well i mean uh
i may have i made it as a starter i mean
the difference was that uh
after five or six innings i was i have
no gas left so i mean i have to
re
uh do my whole pitching and uh
invent some pieces throat something
different so i can't stay for a little
bit longer i mean if if i have to make
that adjustment i would have done it but
i think that they did the right thing
just putting me on
[Laughter]
what was that like though to be sent to
the bullpen
it was different although i have a
little experience in the minor leagues
then that uh that i was able to
obviously it's different okay the matter
list uh compared to the big leagues but
it's the same game all right so i mean i
have like i said i have a little
experience and uh
i use that experience to apply to the
business and uh definitely have to be a
little more sharp and and quicker to
to um
to warm up that was a problem that i
have that i it took a little bit too
much time to warm up when i was in the
movie could you say to the hitter
this is the pitch that's coming
like could you tell them what's coming
and they still couldn't hit it
then
that's the only thing that i didn't do
for
for 17 years as a closer
they knew
the only thing i didn't do that was
how many pitches could you throw
well i mean if i have to then i mean i i
work a lot on the change in uh
the fastball and the uh sinker so i have
four pieces there that i can use for
15 pitches
uh for in an inning that was perfect i
mean you heard the uh the aspiration
that it is not broken don't you yeah
all right
how would you pitch to jeter
well i mean uh you have to move around
the play you know because i mean if you
stay around in one play you
he will hurt you so you have to stay in
him and wave for him and down and up and
and making a little bit uncomfortable
how would you pitch to a-rod
uh well i did push to error tight in and
low and away
tight and low and away
high and low and away yes all right
games on the line you got jeter or a-rod
who do you want to face
both well uh if i had to choose i wanted
to face era even though he can uh damage
you with a home run i was saying as
derek but derrick i think was more
clustered on those situations have you
been watching the documentary
uh no i have not
where you live you live through it yeah
i know that i'm in there
something about him
you're one of the reasons why he has a
documentary
i guess
uh do you have a
is there a negative story
that you have on jeter like everything
is you know everything's you know all
these uh flowers you know is there a
funny story about jeter
well i mean uh
we have a lot of stories that will stay
with us i will tell you those right now
maybe in a hundred years
but uh the only thing that i have with
there was i was watching i think i was
retired already and i was watching in
2014 hit the ball hard
okay and and i thought he thought that
the ball was going over the fence
and he started jogging and the ball hit
the top of the fence and the ball came
back and he almost got thrown out on
second base
that i never saw from him you know he
was so aware of the game
and what was going on that he will never
make those mistakes
but for some reason that day
he did that and uh i'm sure he will
remember
that the day of uh
that he died
okay
like that's the bad story about derek
jeter he almost got thrown out at second
base come on moe
yeah
a man like him i mean i would never
expect that to happen
that's where it is to me i would never
expect that to happen because i mean he
again he was so aware of what's going on
in the ball game that uh
and that's a big mistake that's mental
mistake and he don't make those mental
mistakes too often explain to me your
role with barry larkin on uh introducing
baseball uh in pakistan india and the
middle east
well our role i mean byron myself it's
just teach the game of baseball i mean
uh
besides business let's just
introduce them
to a game that we love that we have
passion and uh why not they have
opportunity to be taught the right way
and uh and have an opportunity to play a
different uh
level of baseball so i mean that's what
i'm excited about patrick i mean it's
something that we're taking it's like a
teaching a youngster they don't have
uh equipment to play but they have the
desire and the ability to do i was one
of them but i didn't have no equipment
then and uh but i have the desire and
the passion to play and learn
about the game and uh i got that
opportunity and i take advantage of the
opportunity so we wanted to uh create
that and develop them in a special way
that uh they can play a different level
baseball
anybody know how many plate appearances
mariana rivera had in his entire career
not not known for his slugging ability
but uh anybody ain't got to get yeah i
got 12. 12 plate appearances todd 17.
satan i'm going to go 37. marv
i'm going to go 18.
mo you know how many don't you
no i don't know i don't know i didn't
hit that but i would say around
maybe around 10. i got you had four
plate appearances
[Laughter]
four
four come on you got a walk an rbi
a strikeout
and no hits
okay but tell me can you name it do you
need them
can you name the appearances okay i
remember
and i have feeling the world series okay
don't don't don't don't
i have those and then during the uh i
remember one with the atlanta i hit the
ball i didn't strike i'll hit the ball
and they got dope for the ball see
that's that's that base is loaded
another one with uh
with philly i strike out that the guy
threw about six uh sliders i mean
uh
and then one in uh arizona i mean i have
you so a lot i i guarantee it's more
than four then
so you better check on that i got four
plate appearances during your career
really oh come on man that's you gotta
go deep into that i'm telling you
how would you have done against you
oh man that's a great question
then i don't know i mean uh poorly i
would say yeah
definitely yeah yeah that upper man i
was in the american league
okay i hear i hate when we when we play
uh interlink i saw
i know i'm not i just said you had four
plate appearances i mean you're still
the greatest closer of all time you just
i might have been i might have been able
to strike you out at the plate mo
[Laughter]
because i i would have kept it in tight
and then i would have had a way i would
have i would have traded you just like
you were a-rod
uh big papi did okay against you what
was the scouting report pitching to him
i mean again i mean
any left-handed hitter that i was
pushing against i mean i was going in in
tight and then if they open up the play
i mean i have a lot of
uh
play on the outside corner so i mean
i have no problem i mean think about it
when we face a guy for 17 years or
i mean they've seen you for all those
times
at some point they're going to hit the
ball
but that's okay that's okay because i
mean again i always say they have uh
they have to eat too you know
[Laughter]
what's the home run you gave up where
you go oh
like soon as you threw it
you knew it was
it was gone
uh there were a few of those not many
how many no i didn't say many few can be
fueled
no
the guy uh make contact and he's okay
that's out get the next hitter
was there one though that you went wow
that's impressive
well one uh my wife hit a ball i think
that's the one that i ever that i i
remember of um
we're playing a yankee stadium we were
winning by
one or two runs something like that and
i was fishing up
and i striking out many times and uh for
some reason and he never swung the first
fish so this fish was
down and in
and he just went at it and hit the ball
and the ball went so high that i
definitely thought it was a
a fly ball to center field and then when
i turned around i saw bernie in number
51 going
a full steam back to the fence and uh
the ball hidden the black on the old
venue oh but then we went to the moon
first
[Laughter]
so this is mark maguire who hit it to
the moon
what is that mark maguire is the one who
hit the moon
oh that's great went to the moon first
uh
hey it's great to talk to you mo and uh
my best to barry larkin and what you
guys are trying to uh do in the middle
east with uh bringing baseball there
well i mean again i mean
it's something that we are inspired
something that we are delighted
something that we're looking for
you know again i mean barry and myself
and
the team that we have that we form it's
amazing team with the talent and
and the passion then you know that when
you have passion to do all these things
a lot of positive things happen
okay so we are we have they have i mean
uh
two billion
new fans that need to see the game yeah
they need to know about the game they
need to learn about the game you know i
mean uh you mentioned about cricket they
have
900 million fans of uh uh cricket you
know so and those
people definitely had to be the next
mariano rivera next their jitter or
on and on
you know so and that's that's why we
are excited because
we have the opportunity to develop them
in a social way and and
i'll be proud of that
good to talk to you again mo thanks for
joining us
thank you for having me that's mariana
rivera the new baseball league it's
launching in dubai and
india pakistan middle east and barry
larkin's involved in that